when your son looks at you and says mama
look you won bullies don't win and I had
baby they talked because we're gonna go
in there we're gonna teach them Oh dick
gephardt is gone forever Democrats are
back in power some of them look nothing
like the Democrats you remember and some
of the most radical are taking spots on
key committees the congresswoman were
seated to lab you just saw raving there
in the video she's on the House
Oversight Committee she's joined there
by Alexandria Acacio Cortes of New York
will they be very different from the
Democrats they replace independent
women's voice senior fellow Lisa booth
joins us tonight for a preview on that
loser
hurry oh I'm mesmerized by the tape we
just played exactly well as you
mentioned she's gonna be one of the new
members of the House Oversight Committee
and look the House Oversight Committee
they have the broadest authority to
investigate and so that's really gonna
be the primary committee that's going
after the Trump administration and
trying to you know see what they can
come up with right and to just today the
House Oversight Committee who's chaired
by Elijah Cummings sent a letter to the
White House saying that they are
investigating the White House over the
way that they give out security
clearances so they're looking in to
Michael Flynn Jared Kushner and a
variety of other members of the
administration Elijah Cummings has also
said that they're going to be looking
into things like president Trump's
zero-tolerance policy with immigration
also Scott Pruett his time as EPA
director so the Oversight Committee is
going to be incredibly aggressive and
you can see that to by some of the
members like Rashida to leave and
Alexandria Kashia Cortez who were named
to be part of this committee dan Kildee
who is part of the steering committee
which is the committee that chooses the
members that are going to be on
committees said that he chose these
members because they're going to be
aggressive and going after the Trump
administration do you think that's a
promise we should take seriously a
hundred percent Tucker I mean look think
about it this way Tucker so the House
Democrats only have control of the house
right so there's only so much
legislation you can really move forward
most of the bills that are passed in the
house are gonna go die in the Senate so
then what do you do as a body their
objective is going to be
investigating the Trump administration
this is going to be the primary goal of
House Democrats in rubber to Alexander
Acosta Cortez I think we have this tweet
if we can put it up there she tweeted
out to John jr. she said I have noticed
that jr. here has a habit of posting
nonsense about me whenever the Moller
investigation heats up please keep it
coming jr. it's definitely a very very
large brain idea to troll a member of a
body
they'll have subpoena power in a month
so she's already basically put out there
via Twitter what her objective is is
this incoming member of the Oversight
Committee so the Trump administration
should buckle up it's gonna be a lot of
pain over the next two months a lot of
negative headlines and this was really
what Democrats are after over the next
two two years here well we at least
settled the question of whether AOC runs
her own Twitter account answered yes she
does I think she does yes she does the
safe bet it is
Lisa booth thank you thanks Tucker